I gotta say that we got a great show
tonight Heidi yeah this show is packed
tighter than Anthony Weiner's underwear
oh good one okay yeah this crowds more
juice than a Rob's left butt cheek okay
nice topical quit banner well it's
another direct hit from the SS Coco was
that supposed to be funny
speaking of funny you know it's a great
show the soup on e yeah yeah that's it's
a great show what's your point well that
shows always hilarious then the host has
socks appeal socks appeal what sorry sex
appeal Andy what do you do with your ear
it's itchy okay hold on a second this is
no no no no no just dead no no don't go
back there just tell us who's on the
show
[Applause]
no no no stop please hi oh hi hi hi
Conan Joel have you been feeding Andy
lines through an earpiece
oh no yes sorry yes how long has this
been going on not long at all Jill like
every show since 2006 oK you've been
feeding Andy his cues since 2006 well
I've been doing it for the leprechaun
Ryan Seacrest since 2002 all right we
have a great show tonight from the TNT
series King and Maxwell Rebecca remains
on the show Joel McHale is Joel McHale
is way prettier than Rebecca oh man all
Mikhail's way prettier than this series
lead Darren Criss he should be on Glee
is a very very pretty Joel McHale Joel
McHale shut up musical guest Tom Odell
oh you know who's a great musical guys
to turn the krail I watched the live 500
episode of the soup August 21st starring
the gorgeous Joel McHale sing it make
sure to watch the live hundred 500 I
can't do it we'll be right back Jimmy go
[Applause]